[Music]
thank you for coming i'm nick gillespie
editor-at-large at reason and i'm happy
to welcome you to the reason speak easy
a monthly conversation series with
outspoken defenders of free thinking and
heterodoxy in an age of cancer culture
and thought police tonight's guest is
the brilliant maverick columbia
university neuroscientist carl hart
author most recently of the
controversial book drug use for
grown-ups chasing liberty in the land of
fear
in a world where drug legalization
efforts are on the march and the
pernicious effects of drug prohibition
on criminal justice education foreign
policy and racial and ethnic communities
are being scrutinized like never before
carl is breaking bold new ground on how
we think about drug policy substance use
and abuse and individual freedom the
declaration of independence guaranteed
life liberty and the pursuit of
happiness for all of us as long as we
don't disrupt anybody else's ability to
do the same says carl that means we get
to live our life as we choose as we see
fit
taking drugs is a part of that for a lot
of americans
he writes that his use of drugs
including heroin and other substances
helps him be a better person i do not
have a drug use problem he declares
never have each day i meet my parental
personal and professional
responsibilities i pay my taxes serve as
a volunteer in my community and
contribute to the global community as an
informed and engaged citizen
we're going to talk about all of that
tonight his path-breaking research on
addiction how he turned from an ardent
supporter of the drug war to one of its
leading critics
elitism within the legalization movement
and now he talks with his kids and his
students some of whom are here tonight
about responsible drug use
and we're going to have plenty of time
for audience q a so start thinking about
that you will be asked to speak into a
microphone you can give your name or a
fake name if you prefer that might be
more fun so get your questions ready and
now carl welcome thank you nick all
right so drug use for grown-ups which
came out last year extends and deep in
some of your arguments and points
you made in your 2013 book high price
give us the elevator pitch of drug use
for grown-ups what's its main argument
and what are you hoping to accomplish
with it yeah first of all i just want to
say thank you for uh putting this
together thank reason um you want a few
people who i actually uh interact with
today so i'm really happy to be here
with you well thank you that's very
flattering
i question i question your uh chara you
know your choice but uh
you know you're not hurting anyone so
um you know uh today is april the 4th um
and it's about seven o'clock
um
it's almost
it's 54 years
and almost to the minute and that martin
luther king jr was assassinated uh he
was assassinated about 605 central time
uh in memphis which would be 705 uh
our time here
so almost to the minute um
mlk was excited was assassinated and you
asked about the book
and
his sort of thinking and people like mlk
influenced my thinking with this book um
i
was thinking about
uh mlk fannie lou hamer a number of my
heroes from the civil rights movement
um and their
sort of uh constant harping on the
declaration of independence and i wanted
to know like why and so i had to reread
the declaration of independence they
they make us read this when we're like
12
when it's not relevant to 12 year olds
because
12 year olds don't have any liberty
their parents tell them what to do
and then we don't ask the americans to
read it anymore and
many americans think they know what it's
about when in fact they don't for
example the left has conceded
the sort of principles in the
declaration to the right and then the
right the many times they want to
control you and not tell you uh
uh really understand what it means it
means liberty for some people well the
thing that really influenced me about
the declaration was this idea of
all of us are born with these three
birthrights life liberty and pursuit of
happiness among others
and it says that they can't be taken
away from us and then in the very next
sentence it says something like
government should be created to protect
or secure these rights and when they
don't when they fail to do that
governments should be disbanded
and americans don't know that what that
simply means is that we can live a life
like we see fit as long as we don't
prevent any other people from pursuing
these rights that's that's what it means
and so i thought about it from
the thing that i had been studying for
about 30 years drugs and i thought like
why am i upset
about people's use of drugs when
someone like me giving these drugs to
people every day in the lab every day
giving drugs like crack cocaine
methamphetamine
um opioids and other drugs i realize now
i made a big mistake by not applying to
colombia
you know but
yeah thank you for clarifying that
we we give these drugs to research
participants who meet stringent sort of
entry requirements for the study but the
point is
the point is is that we give these drugs
to people and we do so because of your
tax dollars and we do so in order to
understand what these drugs do and don't
do we do so to help develop better
treatments uh and so forth but the point
is is that we do so
without any untoward effects and we've
given thousands of doses of these drugs
and most of the people are really happy
after they receive
some of these drugs
and so it really got me the thinking
about why are we so upset as a society
and we are upset as a society not
because of the drugs or the drug effects
but what we have said the this type of
drug use means
and who's using these drugs
and so i wrote this book in order to
show
the public the american public the
global public that most of the people
who use drugs the drugs that we're
concerned about the psychoactive
substances like cocaine psilocybin mdma
heroin you name it most of the people
who use these drugs
are people like me well not black but
they're mainly white
but they're middle class
and they are well off
they take care of their families they're
responsible people
they even sometimes become presidents
because presidents have used these
substances when they were in their youth
uh and
i i got to thinking about the fact that
the illicit drug trade is a
multi-billion dollar industry which
could not be supported by people who
don't have money meaning that the people
who are using these drugs are people who
have jobs people who are
well functioning in society and so i
wanted to
uh present a more realistic view
of the psychoactive substance user and
that's one of the reasons that i wrote
the book another reason i wrote the book
is that i wanted to also kind of expose
the hypocrisy
as it relates to
uh some of the claims that we've made
about what drugs do the sort of drug
addiction is a brain disease model i
wanted to
deconstruct that and
present evidence to show how
that's more myth than reality um i i
wanted to also help people to understand
that the sort of policies or drug
policies we're not based on pharmacology
but they're based on our sort of racism
classes and uh and the rest of these
sort of isms
more so than pharmacology uh i wanted
people to understand how with the
so-called opioid crisis how we overcount
the numbers in order to
inflate those numbers and so i wanted to
show people
how death investigations are done when
it comes to drugs for example
most of the people who die from these
things called drug-related overdoses
they have multiple drugs in their
systems and
the people who are doing the death
investigations don't measure the drug
levels so you don't know which drug
actually caused that effect and then
there are other kinds of problems like
the people who are doing the death
investigations are largely not qualified
there are people who are corners and the
thing that is required to be a coroner
is a high school diploma um and then you
go to a place like california the the
lead sort of death investigator in most
of the counties
uh is the sheriff and so you you see how
these things um the how the bias
happened with these things so i wanted
to point out all of these sort of things
but most importantly
coming back to mlk
i wanted to show people when we think
about the effects of these drugs
the predominant effects of the drugs
that we're talking about are positive
and people
um experience uh all of the sort of
pro-social things that we say we value
like people become more forgiving more
empathetic they become
magnanimous they become more forgiving
just all of these sort of things
that we
uh oftentimes overlook when we talk
about drug use
and so i want to also help people to
understand
that
this activity requires a tremendous
amount amount of responsibility and most
people exercise
as much responsibility in this activity
as they do with other activities in
their life although that's not the story
that we are presented in the public so
i think that's more than an elevated
pitch but that's that's that's a pretty
uh pretty uh high elevator right so
we're going to like the empire state
building thank you for that though
let's before we we go further let's
define some of your key terms you know
your your title mentions grown-ups uh
what do you what do you mean when you
say this you're talking about drug use
for grown-ups you're not talking about
drug use for
kids unborn children you know pets or
anything what counts as a grown-up yeah
i wanted to make sure when i when i
include a grown-up in the title i wanted
to make sure people who uh were less
than genuine in this conversation
uh
wanted to make sure that they were uh
uh neutralized so one of the one of the
things that we do with this conversation
we prevent grown-ups from having this
conversation by saying what about the
kids and so i wanted to make sure that
the what about the kids was not going to
be the showstopper here i mean
i have children my youngest is 21
but
there are activities in which
adults uh
engage
and
and they have children that they don't
want their children to engage you can
think about uh you can have kids who are
very young kids and you don't want them
to engage in sexual intercourse
but you don't stop having sexual
intercourse because you don't want it
about the children yeah
no one no one's telling asking you about
what about the children why do you have
your door closed what about the children
you know and so but we do that with
drugs and so i wanted to make sure that
that didn't happen in this conversation
so it's it's people who you know
legal age of majority but it's also
people who are
can handle drugs responsible absolutely
so another sort of thing that i wanted
to head off too was this notion about uh
people who are having problems in life
in general i mean some people who are
having problems in life in general
particularly now with covert life is
just hard in general and some people
just don't have enough practice with
certain responsibility skills and so
they
they may mess up in this area
or or in or in this area and so i wanted
to make sure people understood that i
was not speaking to the entire
population and so if i was going to
think about people for example who are
having problems in life because of i
don't know because of co-occurring
psychiatric illnesses um i would have to
address all of those illnesses and the
various nuance that that come with them
and this book is not that kind of book
and so i wanted to make it clear i was
not talking about that group of people
and some people
took it as me saying that you could only
use drugs if you meet my definition of
grown-up no that's not what i'm saying
what i'm saying is that
this is who i am speaking to that's
that's the only point that i that's
that's that's the point can you talk a
bit about you know
discussions of drug use as you were
pointing out immediately conflate use
and abuse and you know we
have and i guess it's really after about
30 years of advertising campaigns to say
be a responsible drinker that exists in
our kind of collective unconscious
but then when you say be a you know be a
responsible pcp user be a responsible
weed user this we haven't quite got
there
what how do you define kind of
responsible use or or adult use and
addiction like how because i want to
talk with you about how you you conceive
of addiction in a different way than i
think most of us have been taught to and
the way certainly the rehab and recovery
system does
but you know just in a colloquial way so
yeah so when i think of the way that i
define addiction in the book
was the the definition that we use in
medicine and science
it's in the dsm the diagnostics it's
statistical manual of the the american
psychiatric association it's a simple
definition um it's where you have these
impairments in your psychosocial
functioning you failed to
meet obligations at work at school
you take more of the substance more
often than you initially planned um i
feel like you've been reading my
personnel file
exactly that's one component so you you
you meet uh some some number of symptoms
that's one component but also these
symptoms have to cause impairment
significantly significant impairment
or they cause the user to be distressed
and oftentimes um the people when
they're making this diagnosis or they're
thinking about addiction they don't do
this second component that it causes
significant impairment or the person is
distressed
so for example like uh me failing to
meet an obligation that we typically
have in the family um say like
thanksgiving dinner let's just say that
for example um uh
in my family i have some people who
support trump and i usually go to
thanksgiving dinner uh but since the
trump era
i don't go
and i'd much rather be using a
psychoactive substance now
and i i am not distressed by that now
now some people
might say you know the oh you you meet
this symptom but no the symptom has to
cause distress or significant impairment
and clearly that doesn't happen but
that's an example of why it's so
important to go to the second component
of making the diagnosis now one of the
things that i talked about in the book
was i wanted to make sure people
understood that i wasn't talking about
drug addiction so like the vast majority
of people who use psychoactive substance
do not meet criteria for addiction you
know um
but yet uh
almost all of the conversation in the
country surrounding these drugs focus on
addiction whether you turn you turn on
your television set some movie some tv
programs some tv series in the media you
name it it focuses on addiction even
though
that's not what predominantly happens
with these substances so it would be
like saying i'm interested in a certain
type of german car i don't know a
mercedes bmw and you go online to find
out about these cars and the only thing
you find out about it are crashes that
happened in these cars and that's what
we do with drugs in our society and and
so
i wanted to make sure that people
understood
that i was not here to reinforce this
inappropriate focus on drug addiction uh
that's not to say that people
don't have problems with drugs because
some people certainly do
but that's not this book that's every
other book can you broadly talk about
how um
you know why do people use drugs um in
in a responsible way you know what what
do they get out of that
um you know and obviously that's a broad
question because different substances
have different effects people want
different things at different times but
you know what's what's why do why are we
drawn as human beings to uh altering our
consciousness
uh that that's a question that anybody
knows this audience can answer if you
all have alcohol on your table i mean or
if you talk something before you came
here you you you do so in order to alter
your mood or to
preserve a move state
and so it's a sort of
simple thing particularly when we think
about the drugs that i'm talking about
cocaine the opioids mdma psilocybin
cannabis these are what the government
calls illicit drugs that's right which
is
fascinating and uh you know it's
supposed to be kind of a medical
conversation but illicit is a moral term
yeah they're not even just saying
illegal it's
something sketchy about using no
absolutely and we want to be careful
about even calling these things like
medical terms because we don't think of
alcohol in terms of medical use uh we
don't want medicine controlling people's
sort of uh desire or ability to alter
their mood you never want i mean because
medicine functions as cops and in this
sort of setting it's like why do you
want to have go to your doctor and ask
for a prescription for alcohol that's
silly but that's what we are kind of
asking people to do and that's that's
really silly when you think about it and
so when i when i think about the
substances that we're talking about
why people take them they take them for
really to alter their mood to feel
better to uh
be more open to be uh more kind to have
a different perspective
look at things differently a wide range
of reasons is why people take these
substances but notice most of these
reasons are there are all pro-social
reasons we want to encourage this sort
of thing in our society you think about
it's like
ultimately people feel better
and so if you feel better you're more
likely to treat other people better and
that's one of the things that i try to
emphasize in the book you know it's it's
really about me
having to think about the impact of my
behavior
on the
other people particularly subordinates
and wanting to make sure i didn't
somehow negatively impact uh the uh my
behavior that negatively impacted
subordinate or people in my life uh and
that's one of the things that happens
with some of the
struggles because uh
i become more cognizant of
of other people
in the world and we don't emphasize that
enough in our society so it's drugs not
hugs drugs not hugs or maybe drugs and
then well that could be well i mean you
know if you're with your significant
other or people with whom you care uh
hugs are nice i mean drugs and hugs are
nice you know so yeah why not both
exactly
um you know i i also know uh like i
don't drink alcohol anymore i'm proudly
i guess i only know uh parent people in
my family back to my grandparents and i
am the third generation in a row to have
a problem with alcohol so i don't do it
anymore i take other drugs and most
people tell me i'm a better person for
it as you write about which is like you
know i mean it's pretty gutsy even you
know he's a tenured guy so
you know you really have to certainly
[ __ ] up in order to get fired but like i
know i write and read a lot about drug
policy when a guy says i use drugs they
make me a better person i'm like wow i
know that truth but it's still kind of
stunning to read that in print uh so
thank you for doing that thank you
like
can you briefly sketch like at what
point obviously intoxicants
and mood altering things have are always
kind of suspicious and you know even in
the bible there's cases where you know
sometimes you're exhorted to drink other
times you're you're not you know jesus
made water into wine so he obviously you
know had some uh you know interest in
altering his mood but
what is the
what is the um
uh you know like what's the origins of
our fear you know you talk about chasing
liberty in the land of fear our fear
about the particular types of drugs that
you're talking about because alcohol you
know you know alcohol has been around
forever we did go through a phase of
prohibition but you know what when did
it become like what are the roots of
the drug war as we know it on the
substances that you're writing about you
know some people are they genuinely fear
uh that if you take
some substance let's just say heroin
that heroin will just get a grip on you
and you can't uh control it and the drug
controls your behavior there are some
people who actually believe that
ignorant nonsense i mean there are
people that believe that and there are
people who have used heroin who promote
that sort of thing in part because it's
the only way that person could be could
receive love from the society because if
you say oh i once had a heroin problem
but i found jesus i'm okay now and then
now you're welcomed back into the
society it's the only way you can't say
that yeah i did i do heroin every now
and then i'm good no i don't need your
help i'm good now you can't say that in
our society uh because
of this narrative was it always that way
or when did no yeah
get to that absolutely it wasn't always
it wasn't always that way
then we uh
associated
certain drugs with groups that we don't
like in the society for example we
associated the opioids with
chinese uh
chinese who had come over to help build
the railroads and some brought with them
smoking opium and then they opened up
opium shops and opium dens and people
frequent those places and they did well
financially in places like san francisco
new york city
and certain white businessmen were not
happy about how well they were doing
they started to pass local ordinance
that
forbid uh
white folks from going into those places
and they eventually tried to shut them
down and
uh and and so that was one reason for
related to the opium when you think
about something like cocaine cocaine was
quite pervasive in our society in fact
coca-cola um they
put it in the fountain drink
and made a lot of money in places like
atlanta um and black people were
excluded from the fountain so it was
really only available to white folks in
that sort of setting but then coca-cola
bottled it i believe in 1809 they
bottled it now everyone has it in
coca-cola and other places and then you
start to see these sort of negative
reports associated in cocaine use with
black people saying that black men
started they would put white women into
slavery prostitution
um black men they said were impervious
to 32 caliber bullets
so you can unload your 32 caliber weapon
into their chest and they keep coming if
they were on cocaine
and so it caused some southern uh police
forces to shift to the 38 caliber weapon
so you see
all of these sort of stories that are
built up around these drugs uh promoting
the sort of fear uh of certain drug use
by certain groups and i should say that
this fear was not only promoted by like
white americans it was also promoted by
like black americans and also some
chinese americans particularly those who
wanted to be seen
as respectable members of their
community and so this was just like
today you you see all of these
communities participating in the
vilification of certain drugs and so it
didn't change that's one of the things
that i didn't i haven't done as good of
a job of doing is to show how
all americans participated in this sort
of vilification of drugs and the people
who certain people who use these drugs
and so that fear
uh
then uh turned into this notion to this
sort of real event where people realize
they can make fear off of this money
people like harry anslinger he was the
first bureau of chief chief of the
bureau of narcotics he became the the
bureau chief in the early 1930s and he
stayed there until 1960s and he was the
um
well andrew mellon uh niece he married
andrew mellon's niece and that's how he
got that job at like 20 something years
old uh and he would say things like um
uh
cannabis made black people think that
they were good as white people and that
was a fear kind of thing but he also got
his budgets increased by promoting this
kind of fear the bureau of narcotics was
built up between the years 1932-19
they really got built and he took over i
mean he basically took a lot of the
arguments about liquor or about alcohol
prohibition and then mapped them on to
absolutely other substances absolutely
because alcohol prohibition ended in
1933 and so they had to find a new uh
hated substance and he found cannabis
and so which was identified often with
mexicans right to go with mexicans and
also blacks uh in the south and also
black people here in new york city like
mayor laguardia at the time uh was
trying to uh
give some pushback to this notion of all
people mayor laguardia in 1944 released
this report saying that this is nonsense
what ann slinger is saying uh but
anselinger
saw very early that if you use this fear
and attach it uh to drugs in certain
groups it could really increase your
budgets and this is what we have seen
today when we think about the war on
drugs and the propping up of police
budgets and prison authority budgets
also even tv stations got a lot of money
based on the drug war so a number of
people
uh understand that this fear is tied to
their pockets yeah i always think of the
drug war i mean you think of it in kind
of a small way but it's shot through
every aspect of our society i mean your
kids when they go to school they get
dare it's in our foreign policy it's in
our police budget it's on tv uh i'm old
enough to remember video games where at
the end of you know you would kick
somebody's ass in mortal kombat and you
know somebody would come out and say
real winners don't use drugs which is
one of the biggest lies that has ever
been foisted on people right but and i
remember there were
urinal cake uh holders women you won't
understand this but urinal cake holders
that we would
in you know in urinals i would say just
say no to drugs and i always wondered if
the person who came up with that was
secretly a legalizer because it's like
you know you're pissing on the idea of
saying just say no to drugs it could
have been a legalizer but you got to
also remember the people who were doing
the urine testing right they got a lot
of money off of the war on drugs in fact
they did
like some of the first surveys that
showed
in 1989 september 1989 uh in the united
states
more than 60 percent of americans said
that the number one problem
facing the united states was drugs
more than 60 60 percent of adult
americans people who
we walk around with now in the face of
homelessness
poverty
uh you got a
global you got the global warming issue
you have all of these issues and 60
percent of americans said drugs facing
the country what's the number one
problem and that survey was conducted by
the folks who were doing urine testing
and and so they made sure that the
american public uh uh were frightened
about this this is maybe they were
saying that people didn't have enough
drugs that was the problem i don't know
that would have been nice but
we saw so what we saw with the people
going to jail was different yeah uh we
are having a different conversation
about drugs now right though i mean and
over the past
you know you can start i don't know when
you want to say like the peak of the
drug war and i might be too optimistic
but we're having conversations about
legalization the uh uh house of
representatives just passed a bill to
legalize marijuana at the federal level
it's not going to go anywhere but it's
it's a first
um you know is a legalization or kind of
drug use for grown-ups is this a
conversation that america is finally
ready to have you know that that we're
going to use a wide variety of
substances to get where we want to be
you know not just pharmaceuticals not
just booze not just things like exercise
and you know and and yoga or meditation
um you know
what what's driving that is it that
we've you know we've opened up our
pharmacopoeia and we reckon you know
like in a world where you're everybody's
taking viagra and prozac does it make
sense to say like well you know maybe an
opioid now and then or or a psychedelic
um why why are we more open to
legalization than we were well i i want
to push back on the sort of optimism a
little bit um
let's think about since we're in new
york city let's think about
stonewall was it 69 it wasn't stonewall
was 69. and so stonewall is where
the gay community
and the police clashed and because the
police were
engaged in homophobic behavior um
now in 1969
this happened where they were arresting
people for being gay essentially
now
in 1969
and today it's it's different
you know we still have place some place
to go we
and i went to the university of wyoming
where matthew shepard was murdered um
so as i think about
stonewall i think about matthew shepard
i think about those kind of things it's
like when we say
yeah we made progress but those people
who are negatively affected by our
stupidity and ignorance
they are no less they were no less human
then
than they are now so just because we
don't get it
doesn't mean that somehow their humanity
somehow was different it wasn't the same
is true with drugs drug users just
because the society is having some
moment where they want to talk about
marijuana legalization the person who's
using heroin or mdma or cocaine or
something else
their humanity
is still equated with my humanity but
just because the society doesn't get it
and now they only want to talk about
cannabis
i can't celebrate that i because i have
to think about that poor person
whose humanity is not acknowledged
at that same level as mine and that's
that's how that's where i'm at but we
are talking about you know legalizing
plant-based drugs uh you know some
mushrooms in places we are mdma we're
talking about decriminalizing
plant-based drugs and we're talking
about
the
legalizing cannabis largely at the state
level like new york we recently did this
uh and we're doing so because we saw
the tax revenue that were generated in
colorado and and washington and tax
revenues that are being generated around
the country and so that's
fueling this sort of uh legalization
push
uh but since we talk about
decriminalization and legalization we
should explain the difference sure
so when we think when i say legalization
i mean just like what we do with alcohol
or tobacco and we're doing now with
cannabis in some states uh if you're of
the right age you can legally purchase
it and you can legally sell it as well
uh in shops and so forth that's
legalization decriminalization means
that you if you get caught with a
personal amount uh amounts that have
been deemed for personal use you won't
get a criminal sanction or
a criminal penalty but you might get
some sort of administration
administrative fine or something but you
typically you wouldn't go to jail
and
sales of that substance remains illegal
meaning that
you still have to go to the black market
uh and get the substances that you don't
know anything about the quality
so you still are putting yourself at
risk in that sense and also you still
give police a lot of discretion because
in new york city new york state we
decriminalized cannabis in 1977
but under uh
many mayors starting with rudy giuliani
people in the city were being arrested
for cannabis and personal use even
though it is decriminalized it has been
decriminalized in the state since 1977
same is true in baltimore where they
decriminalized in 2014 between 2015 and
2017
1596 people were arrested for
simply possessing cannabis 96 of those
people were black because of police
discretion and so you see how even with
decriminalization
these things get abused and people still
suffer and more importantly
people
lives are at risk because of tainted
substances and that's the most important
thing
and that's why i it's hard for me to get
excited about people talking about
decriminalization without even
understanding the difference between
legalization and decriminalization so
what is the best way then to move
conversations forward about things like
legalization where you're not only
legalizing the use
and the sale but also the production
you know how how do we get there because
it it does seem broadly we're moving
towards
we're we're having a better conversation
about drugs than we were 50 years ago
certainly
yeah [ __ ] i was just born 50 years not
about 50 years ago so that's not really
saying much you know it's like right
it's like saying
whoa
what um
uh interracial marriage was banned in
many places 50 years ago then you say
like well now it's not bad
that's not much that's not much progress
in my mind or
uh
and and so when you say how do we move
forward
the only way i know how to move forward
is to be honest
uh in public and to call people on their
[ __ ] that's the only way i know and
this is not to necessarily embarrass
people but people's lives and help is at
stake and i have to remember that and
and i know that i must treat people well
and i know that i must think of their
humanity in the same way as i think of
mine that's how we move forward when we
stop thinking of other people's humanity
in the way we think of our own we're in
trouble that means that
there are some people for example who
say well you know i'm a physician or i'm
a psychology whatever
i'm thinking about your humanity and i
know what's best for you i don't mean
that i mean
you equate people's humanity like you
equate your own that means that they are
autonomous individuals and they can make
their own decisions even if
those decisions seem to you
not to be the most um
sound decisions but that's not my that's
not my role
unless you know of course there are
other people being
negatively impacted and especially that
person doesn't think about other people
then i may have their intervene but if
not
it's not my business so you know uh part
of your research looks at the and you
were talking a bit about this um with
addicts or people who would would
generally be you know relegated to a
category of not being in control of
themselves not being autonomous and
you've done experiments with people who
use methamphetamine and you find
i mean i i think that's one of the ways
of you allow people to recognize
another person's humanity while they're
making choices you might not understand
but that
you've found that giving small amounts
of money to people
or giving them the option of drugs or
money you found that people are making a
wide variety of decisions that doesn't
comport with that addict model where
you're kind of a zombie enthrall to a
drug could you talk a little bit about
that yeah so um
at the core i am a a psychologist a
behaviorist at my core
and
when you think about the principles of
behaviorism it's very simple it's that
uh there are consequences to behavior
that's that that's it and so if you can
um figure out the the things we call
contingencies that is the consequences
and the end to seasons the things that
set up uh the consequences then you can
figure out how to alter people's
behavior you can
control people's behavior or you can
understand why people are behaving than
the way they behave and so all we wanted
to do was to show that drug taking
behavior followed the same principles as
any behavior so if you present the
choice between something like taking a
hit of a drug whether it's
methamphetamine crack cocaine and an an
attractive alternative attractive being
that it too can control behavior or
it's powerful enough to influence
behavior then you would see that a
choice to self-administer a drug like
crack or methamphetamine
could be malleable or it could be
altered it could be decreased if you
simply have an attractive alternative
that's potent enough and so if you
increase if you offer something as
little as five dollars versus a hit uh
methamphetamine or a hit of crack
cocaine you'll see that they'll take um
the drug and the money about on the same
a number of opportunities but if you
increase the money to something like 20
they'll almost always take the the
the money i mean because it just it it
just makes sense and it shows that
people who use drugs can and do behave
rationally as rationally as the rest of
us um they uh there was a time when
people said oh one hit a crack you're
addicted forever then they said the same
thing about methamphetamine then they
said the same thing about heroin and
then the circle the cycle repeats and
then we we go back to say that you know
crack cocaine is the heroine of drugs
yeah and then heroin becomes the
the methamphetamine and then yeah it's a
weird vicious cycle you spend a lot of
time in switzerland um which uh you know
partly because of the way that they deal
with drugs and you know i don't think
anybody here i i've not been to
switzerland but you know it's not the
first place i think of as
you know this is the the civilization
that gave us the cuckoo clock and you
know really uh you know exact changing
of the guards in front of the vatican or
something
what are they doing right about drug
policy and you know what what should we
be learning from these uptight swiss
people
so you're going to make sure i can't
enter the country anymore when i go back
oh yeah i'm sorry about that yeah no no
no no that's a good point i mean
switzerland you know in all seriousness
uh they managed to be neutral during
world war ii you know they that's quite
a feat
when you uh
uh yeah that uh
so i'm not in switzerland because they
are um
what um
they're so laser fair i'm not there
because of that um
and there are some things about
switzerland that i don't like i mean
they really follow the rules like we
can't flush our toilets after 10 o'clock
at night or something like that you know
it's it's or somebody might knock at
your door with a 200 euro fine or
swiss bank frank's pie um
and so
i am in switzerland
uh because
uh people leave me alone um uh i live
next to a park uh
in geneva which is really lovely in the
summertime you see teenagers
out there anywhere from i don't know 14
to
early 20s
smoking cannabis
having a good time is dark
doing alcohol whatever
they have not a care in the world and
the police don't mess with them uh and
those kids growing up in that society
actually know what freedom is and
liberty and having a good time
is and and so uh
my wife and i we just go to the park and
watch the kids uh just have a good time
and and we think we
like can you imagine this happening in
central park without the police coming
over messing with these kids uh it's
just a beautiful thing uh we walk down
the streets and you they
prosecution i mean
prostitution is decriminalized you see
people uh it's not uh
it doesn't look any way like uh
it's uh untoward it's uh people are
kind to each other the police are
they for the most part don't mess with
people um
yeah it's just uh they kind of leave
people alone um and it's a it's a lovely
thing to just see people living and not
fearing uh like safety and that sort of
thing and then the safety concerns i
have in america are largely related to
our police
um
let's uh talk about psychedelic
exceptionalism because you're you're a
critic of that and you're actually more
a critic i think i heard you talking
with ethan nadelman the former head of
the drug policy alliance on a podcast
that he has talking about drug ism
where you know one of the things people
still feel comfortable with saying well
you you know we're all drug users here
but you do certain kinds of drugs so i
don't take you seriously but there is
within the broader drug legalization
movement uh certain people who are
really into psychedelics will talk about
how
you know these drugs are special these
are unique these these are more potent
they're more uh powerful or
and they can't really go into general
circulation you seem to be a critic of
that model um is that am i being
accurate in your view and and what what
where does that stem from yeah so one of
the things i did in in the new book was
um
i came out as a heroin user right
also as a number of other drug use i
said i use
you were really going for the niche
markets right like you know it's like
morning glory seeds banana strings
everything everyone yeah of course throw
that
uh
but i put heroin in the prologue up
front um
in order to
align myself with the most vilify in our
society uh yeah i think only uh juggalos
followers of the insane clown posse are
lower than heroin uses exactly
i did it intentionally uh not that i'm
some connoisseur or i'm an expert you
know at some level i feel like a fraud
right because there are a lot more there
are people who know a lot more about
that substance than i do uh but i i
align myself with that group because
they are the most vilified so i did it
intentionally uh and it's been an
interesting thing
in terms of the press that i've received
uh because the press have tried to
dismiss me because of it
i i said that
i'm a regular heroin user and so regular
for me is
uh
it could be once a month or it could be
once every six months but just regular
that's all it is but that
phrase turned into i shoot heroin every
day that's what that phrase turned into
and um it's been quite incredible
because i thought that um
you know my accomplishments uh if you
really read them
who could argue with the accomplishments
and it's like who wouldn't want their
child to like do this trajectory i mean
and so
uh
i thought that that would be some are
you were you trying to get like a
wheaties box endorsement of you know i
use heroin and i think you should too
you know
i didn't get to colombia by snorting
cocaine i used
you would fair heroin you would think
you absolutely think that's what that
was right the way that it was it was
reported
uh and so
um
you know so it's been good that i had to
experience this because then
again it makes me be even more
sympathetic even empathetic towards
those folks who are being
uh castigated because of this sort of
thing and so
i uh uh
uh when i hear
uh people who are
uh promoting their substance while
disparaging another
um
it it infuriates me because clearly the
person don't un doesn't they don't
they don't understand what is uh how
drugs are classified for one um
many of the drug classifications are
arbitrary and it depends on who's doing
the classifying uh the persons don't
understand about dose they don't
understand about route of administration
they don't understand about setting all
of these things influence the sort of
effects more than even the substances in
many cases and so
um it it
it's maddening um
uh to see uh particular well
it's important for us to know
that folks who are
opinion makers in our society some
writers comedians a number of people who
have the microphone they shape the
opinions and many of them
now it's cool
to use psychedelics
and now they
that's that's sanctioned cool
which is [ __ ] sanctioned cool that's
a that's an oxymoron but people don't
understand that they don't they don't
get it people don't get it uh and and so
being that group of people are
touting the benefits of psychedelics
meanwhile they are
uh
disparaging things like crack cocaine
methamphetamine and heroin uh without
even understanding
so i mean this is a might be one of the
reasons why you got to push a lot of
pushback from within the drug
legalization movement i mean this is a
super radical position where you're not
saying i'm going to leave the power
structure in place and i just want to
put my stuff
is now legal you're saying i want to get
rid of this power structure and stop
having a hierarchy of oh you know like
malt liquor
is not good you know wine is okay uh so
lsd is okay or mushrooms but not heroin
i mean this that's the heart of your
project right yeah absolutely because
you know the
as you know
drug users in general have faced this
sort of uh prejudice uh and then so like
you know what it feels like to face such
prejudice
and now
you want to
promulgate this or you want to uh
uh
do this to another group
uh but it
it
it's one of the more infuriating things
that i face in my life
because i would think that people
understand
that
it's not right
to make anyone feel but on the upside
now you have a better reason to take
heroin right because you're mad i don't
really need a reason you know i'm
this is the lovely thing about being
your own man yeah uh
i do what i want as long as you know i'm
not negatively impacting other people's
sort of experience or their life but
that's a lovely thing with being free
yeah so many people in our society don't
understand what freedom is and that's
one of the reasons i wrote the book
could you demystify you know i i on some
level i apologize for harping on the
heroine but i mean it's a bold
rhetorical move that you made
demystify what it's like to use heroin
because i think most of us
when we think about if we don't have
direct experience or if we do and i you
know i had a friend from college who
uh died of a he he became a junkie and
died of an overdose in the kind of
stereotypical way you know found in a in
a in a bathroom with a needle between
his toes you know it's i mean it's
everything from the man with the golden
arm up through requiem for a dream and
all of this
but when you write and talk about heroin
it's it's almost like um
you know it's uh it's it's a feel good
kind of
pleasant thing and you know it's not
this horrific uh yeah
i i think people like uh william burles
and those guys
they really [ __ ] it up i mean because
um
you know they were looking for
a reason to be hit
and they were looking for things to
write about that were on the edge
and the dumbass society allowed them to
say these things about heroin and be
believed
and so uh it's really
the society got hoodwinked with those
guys and we still celebrate those idiots
you know and so
i
um
if anybody has had i don't know vicodin
uh percocet you had some pain
that's an opioid experience
that's all it is it's it's it's uh it
can be euphoric uh anxiety relieving uh
a wide range of those things it's just
that you
uh with something like heroin straight
heroin real heroin you don't have to
deal with
things like acetaminophen in your
percocet that's far more dangerous uh
can be far more dangerous than heroin uh
if you take too much of it um and so
uh if you've had an opioid for
tooth pain some other type of pain then
you've essentially had heroin it's not a
big deal the reason why it's so
mystified in our society
is because of these people who wrote uh
who were looking for a life who wanted
to look like they were cool and
interesting when in fact they weren't
yeah as a matter of fact in borough's
first published novel under the name
william lee junkie he talks about junk
as a way of life he i mean it's
it's an entire
set of associations that are far beyond
any thing pharmacologically he's talking
about yeah i mean they were frauds i
mean you know it's like
um yeah it's annoying to people who are
really cool and you see these people who
are
uh let's open this up to questions uh
malik can you uh
ask people okay yeah
all right um
raise your hand if you have a question
for carl hart
and wait for malik to uh
i used to live in san francisco and it's
turned into a dystopian nightmare
driven uh by and large by the open
opioid use and fentanyl use on on the
streets
i'm wondering how do you address these
sorts of social concerns
well i used to live in san francisco too
um and i was there recently and i know
the narrative i mean there are people
who use drugs um
and they're also homeless and they are
in those spaces but
this is not because of drugs um
you i think about a place like la which
i know the homeless population or those
numbers better
there are more empty houses in la than
there are
uh homeless people
the problem is
housing lack of housing
lack of ability to pay for housing
our sort of
simplistic way of looking at
drugs and pointing to drugs as a problem
that for why people are experiencing
those problems in san francisco that's
not it the problem is related to the
expense of san francisco i have been
homeless once in my life and it was in
san francisco
i had just got my phd
uh moved from
laramie wyoming to san francisco i had
to sleep
under my desk
and i showered
at the hospital um people didn't know
because it was so damn expensive um and
so this is first time i'm telling that
story publicly but that's a fact and but
yet
we want to blame drugs for what the
people in san francisco experience in
that's like
yeah that's that's what do you do about
people who clearly um are not
flourishing you know they might be
homeless or not but they have a drug
problem and they resist treatment you
know and i say this as a libertarian
like i i don't want to coerce people
into doing things but you know how do
you as a you know either as a
psychologist or as a caring person how
do you deal with that kind of situation
well um people who are not flourishing
so what we should do is maybe let the
experts deal with this first i'm not an
expert in that area and i won't um
the reasons for why people are not
flourishing they vary widely and
in our culture one of the things that's
happened with these damn podcasts and
the rest of these things is that
everybody becomes an expert on
everything and so i uh i you know i know
a lot about structural steel and the
level that jet fuel will or will not
melt it you know and i became
i became kind of an epidemiologist there
in covit so
exactly and so that's that this is the
problem we we need to make sure that uh
if you don't know what you're saying
shut the hell up well i don't know that
we have a lot left to talk about then
but let's go to the next uh question
please malik
thanks mike
so uh in this discussion about
difference between psychedelics and and
other drugs
we have to give credit to people like
roland griffins who's done the research
to help show
utility of those agents for disease
processes
it's been and it's sad that we don't
have that
being
showcased for opium right because
i mean it was the first drug that we
really learned to use well
for treating pain and discomfort
but no one's looking at that anymore
instead of that that science is stronger
than what griffs put out for psilocybin
and yet we don't say you know these are
miracle drugs the opiates were miracle
drugs for
saving disease
um
that was more of a comment my real
statement i wanted to ask the question
about was
uh as a kid we all
most of us first experience illicit
agents when we're in our adolescence and
it makes sense because we're in our
stage of exploration
how did you deal with it with your
children and wanting to do that
exploration
uh as far as making them responsible
during it because
who wants to be responsible when you're
an adolescent yeah and you are
you provide the ultimate instantiation
of the old anti-drug ad i learned it
from you dad
right when the kid fine you know that
father finds his kid using drugs and
so how did you deal with that and i mean
and the students here you know kids stay
in school if you're in carl's class stay
in school but how did you deal with all
this you sound like a rapper now uh
one of the things that used to be in the
old hip-hop sort of psas public service
announcements uh by the way i used to be
in in that game for a little bit i did
some shows with run dmc when i was a kid
and
we all smoked some weeds and together
and and then
uh i would see run dmc um public service
announcements saying stay stay in school
and stay off drugs and i'd be like what
the [ __ ] yeah
so that's who you sound like now uh
um
back to this this issue when you said we
should give credit to roller griffiths
and people like that yeah i i know
roland and and
i also have done the science too and
um you know it's an interesting thing
it's really
um
i've been hoping roland comes out of the
closet about his own views i you know i
i haven't seen him use or anything but
this is just suspicious
and it it would do a lot more good
um and you know
he's could you explain who he is and why
roland griffiths is a researcher at
johns hopkins and
he
like me does
lab work with humans where he gives
psychoactive substances and tests roland
has given drugs ranging from cocaine
nicotine to psilocybin and he has a long
uh impressive career um and uh
he's over 70 now i suspect and
um it'd be nice if he just came out of
the closet too and just said look i've
been i'm responsible i've been doing
this
but he won't i don't i suspect he won't
and so when we are praising people um
how about we see let's let's see first
uh because i think that would go a long
way to
uh dispel these myths about what a drug
typical drug user looks like yeah you
talk a lot in the book about the
chemical closet and so you i mean you
want like
the spartacus moment people like i'm
spartacus and i use heroin i'm spartacus
and i use nicotine no i no uh i want
people to be out of the closet in their
way in their you know it's like i
recognize that some people they put
themselves at risk and of course there's
a lot of risk with what i'm doing uh but
when we started off the talk thinking
about mlk i mean people like him uh who
we admire
um all of them put their selves
themselves at risk that's why we admire
them that's what
fighting for freedom looks like putting
yourself at risk and so
how
how people decide to do that that's fine
i i i don't want to tell them how to do
it but they have to understand that of
course there's risk that's part of it
uh now back to the children um
uh when
i think about my own children
who by the way
were honest students did well
we never
talked about drugs especially about
drugs drugs were
just like we never really talked about
uh
their girlfriends or the
video games anything that they could
potentially i don't know have problems
with um
the thing that we emphasize was
long-term goals we wanted to make sure
that they they made they contributed to
the society in which they were growing
up
and so
you take the sort of uh focus off of
them and you put it outwards like what
are you contributing what are you doing
um and then their performance in school
was like a marker all right if we if
you're doing well in school and you're
doing these other things like they're
playing sports they're doing all these
things that we asked
uh they got into the university that
they wanted to get into they did all of
these things that we ask
that's what we focus on and i should
also say
my children they came with me to the lab
when they were young they were
i don't know since they were able to
walk they would come to the lab and see
me giving a drug to someone and we might
have a conversation about that sort of
thing they had their birthday parties at
the lab because we were poor and that
this was what we did
and so they were always at the lab
but there were no special conversations
about drugs
if one is having special conversations
about drugs
then you probably have lost the battle
this is really about
just raising good decent people
if you raise good decent people and
they're meeting all of these sort of
things that you're requiring of them
that's what you want
this is drugs are not special and so we
didn't want to treat drugs like they
were special
another question
hey there
um so thinking about like taking away
the arbitrary classes off of drugs from
your experience is there
a drug or a substance that actually is
more harmful for people or a society
um
that we might not be aware of because of
our prejudices
well um so my focus has been on drugs
that we're are aware of like cocaine
heroin mdma psilocybin those kind of
things
uh
so outside of those drugs there have
been drugs that have popped up in the
society
that were really dangerous and
concerning
oftentimes these drugs pop up
from people trying to skirt around the
current legal regulations the sort of
prohibition on one drug so i'll give you
an example
in the 1970s and 1980s
uh people were trying to make synthetic
opioids and they were calling it things
like china white
and then there was a compound that was
promising
um um it looked kind of like dimral
which is an opioid and
uh but what happened was that the
compound
some people call it mptp mpb plus but it
ultimately gets converted to mpp plus uh
by the body and it selectively destroys
dopamine cells and dopamine neurons are
important particularly
in the midbrain they're important for
movement when you selectively damage or
destroy these cells you can have
something that looks like parkinson's
disease and so clearly a drug like that
is dangerous and should be banned
but when we're thinking about something
like the actual drug that people were
seeking something like heroin
we don't have that concern that's not an
issue uh and and so um uh as long as we
have this sort of prohibition
the way that we're currently running our
prohibition
we can expect to perhaps
uh see some of these substances pop up
periodically is that what's going on
with fentanyl which is a very useful uh
anesthetic
but it's being used to uh for opioid or
heroin right yeah so uh something like
fentanyl which is an opioid two
uh fentanyl is slightly different
fentanyl does not selectively cause
damage to brain cells uh fentanyl the
concern of fentanyl is that it's so
potent meaning that so a small amount is
required to produce an effect if someone
thinks that they have something like
heroin and in fact they have fentanyl
they may take too much and then overdose
that's the real concern with something
like fentanyl so uh yeah there is a
concern but it's important for us to
realize that fentanyl is an fda approved
medication and it's been approved for
about 50 years now and so
uh fentanyl itself
is a safe medication as long as the
person understands that they actually
have fentanyl and not something else so
it's like boys town there are no bad
drugs right there are no bad boys right
it's just it's the context
context is important can uh malik can we
get a uh microphone up here for uh
charlie at the front table
thank you
maybe you can clear up some
misunderstanding or
just
make me more clear about what you what
your critique of psychedelic
exceptionalism is
is it simply that
um people who promote the use of
psychedelics but then put down these
other drugs are hypocritical
or are you saying that
drugs such as heroin or cocaine
are as efficacious
and healing and potentially
transformational as psychedelic drugs
can be
i'm saying both
uh i i'm saying that people who are
disparaging who are propping up
psychedelic not all but some who are
second uh pumping up psychedelics
propping them up and at the same time
they are disparaging things like heroin
and then if you really think about
heroin the effects and you do it
objectively as i tried to point out in
the book uh heroin in a place like the
heroin clinic in switzerland where uh
people who are being treated for an
opioid use disorder take heroin they
have those sort of transcendent
experiences some of those people with
something like heroin um
certainly heroin can can be that depends
on the setting uh depends on the dose
that depends on the experience of the
user um yeah that's that's what i'm
saying absolutely so would you say drugs
don't really have any inherent um
qualities or characteristics it's is it
always the way that it gets you used to
it no i wouldn't say that um
because you know the drugs have unique
properties um
you think about your cannabis experience
versus your cocaine experience versus
your mdma experience
they have unique qualities
so i want to acknowledge that but what
i'm saying is that uh if persons are
seeking let's say a transcendent
experience
they some if they know what they're
doing they can certainly obtain that
with something like heroin um but it
might be more readily accessible to
someone who
has a tremendous amount of experience
with psilocybin
so they do have their unique qualities
but
they overlap
just as they were about out of time um
and i just wanted to close on
the um topic you were and you've written
about this um you were a drug warrior um
and then you became
a critic of the drug war can you talk
briefly about what flipped that switch
for you and what can society learn
uh from your experience so that we
become you know a better
uh you know we become more critical
readers of of the information that we
get about drugs and hopefully lead to a
you know a better set of policies and
experiences with these substances
well between 1984 and 1988 i served in
the u.s air force uh and so uh in that
period in 1986 in the middle of that
period the country thought that crack
cocaine
or the country was manipulated into
believing that crack cocaine was
the major problem facing the country
even though crack cocaine used
was always relatively low and never
really any
approached anywhere near power cocaine
use levels certainly nowhere near
marijuana use levels or any of these
other drugs uh i got food like everyone
else uh in the air force i was trying to
think about uh how could i best serve my
community
so i went to university while in the air
force um
and i was going with the notion in mind
that i wanted to solve the drug
addiction problem in my community
uh and so one way to do that was to
study neuroscience and try to understand
how neurons in the brain worked try to
manipulate this with drugs in order to
treat people who were suffering for
drugs from drug addiction and i figured
that if i cured drug addiction i could
solve some of the problems in my family
i mean in my family also in my community
uh and then you know that's what i did
for the next 30 years you know
wholeheartedly
working in the lab giving drugs to anim
laboratory animals and humans and
along the way uh the story just started
to fall apart i thought that most people
who use these substances were addicted
turns out the vast majority are not
uh you can't go to work every day and
give drugs to people
who
you thought were irresponsible
uh
people who you thought would not be able
to show up on time would not be able to
follow direction and you see this over
and over again seeing that this this
isn't true
and then reading the literature
starting to see how people were
would get a set of data but didn't have
a different interpretation
you can't be a critical scientist and
not say
start to see
these
uh
these pieces these cracks and then over
time um i i start to realize how much
money was being pumped into the war on
drugs i start to realize that i was a
beneficiary uh my phd was paid for
because of the war on the drugs i got
million dollars of grants because of the
war on drugs uh and then and then i had
to go home to miami uh and see
many of the males my friends my family
members
gone dead or in jail because of the war
on drugs
so
i had to look at myself and think about
my participation
all of those things helped me to change
my mind and then after writing high
price
traveling around the world places like
brazil and seeing that we have exported
our war on drugs and then at the same
time
um i'm being offered some some of south
america's finest cocaine um and from uh
some of the captains of industry all
around the globe
and all of these things cause
cognitive dissonance and then you have
to solve the cause of cognitive
dissonance and this is
uh facing the truth is uh part of the
way i solved the cognitive dissonance
um as a final point um
and and this was uh it was a real
revelation for me um shortly after
george floyd's death
um at the hands of minneapolis police
you wrote a piece in the new york times
and this you know this is like an
instance of critical reading of
something when george floyd's toxicology
report came out you know he had a bunch
of different drugs in his system and you
cautioned and saying like that this data
is almost completely useless the way it
comes out i was thinking about that when
uh the foo fighters drummer taylor
hawkins died recently at the age of 50.
he had a bunch of different drugs in it
what you know just very quickly what
when when we see this thing come out
what should we be looking for as
critical readers so tonight i have with
me uh my uh seminar students it's about
12 of them they're here
and this semester seminar is focused on
basically
toxic drug toxicologies and overdoses
and we're uh looking into the overdose
literature and we
look at some toxicologies
uh
and so one of the things that it's
important for us to do
whenever there are reports out saying
that someone died from an overdose
if you can get the toxicology and then
you will see
drug levels uh in the person systems
oftentimes the drug levels
are don't indicate that the person even
used drugs in the past few dr few days
because you know some of these drugs
stay in your system for several days
but when we see what's reported in the
media
they say oh he used methamphetamine even
though the levels are so low
that it it would suggest that the person
hasn't used for at least 24 hours
and so that's what i try to do when we
have these high-profile cases in the
media i try to get the toxicology and
then we can look and see exactly uh what
is likely likely contributed to the
person's death like in the case of
george floyd the initial reports were
that uh he over he overdosed on fentanyl
and then if you look at the video uh you
see george floyd was interacting with
the police and interacting just like you
would expect
until
they cut off his air supply and that
but
they tried to say that it was the drugs
and so i looked at the toxicology the
levels of fentanyl and george floyd's
system were so low uh um it was it was
highly unlikely that that was the cause
of his death they also said something
about cannabis and methamphetamines
those levels were even lower
uh and so
i just simply went through
what was in his toxicology and
tried to walk the reader through in a
reasoned way
but even publishing that piece was
really difficult uh because again
medicine uh has uh been reluctant uh to
comment on these kind of things uh i
think it's a dereliction of duty quite
frankly um and the police narrative is
the only one that stands and so
in my class this semester i'm trying to
train people to know how to look at
toxicologies and so i won't be the only
one
in the public saying wait a second this
doesn't make any sense
well uh it's an extremely helpful
article uh look it up
i want to uh i want to thank
carl hart uh the book is drug use for
grown-ups uh chasing liberty in the land
of fear thank you for your work thank
you for your service thank you nick
[Applause]